So I'm here with my famous chemist and Nobel prize winners.
Ty Brady gave it to me and we're waiting for the
2015 Nobel prize in chemistry to be announced.
And as usual I have absolutely no idea who it's going to go
to, which is what makes it really quite fun.
But you remember sometimes it goes to more to biology than to
chemistry because there isn't a Nobel prize for biology.
We've already got some chemistry in the medicine prize.
So chemistry has been recognized at least a bit already.
So let's see what happens with chemistry. Are you going to give us a prediction?
I have absolutely no idea who it would be.
Somebody suggested it might be for lithium-ion batteries,
the battery on the mobile phone that you may be watching this on at the moment,
but who knows? It's always the really.
[Inaudible] Academy of sciences has decided to award the
2015 Nobel prize in chemistry jointly
to Tumas Lindahl Paul mode,
rich and as is Sanjana.
Okay.
So I've rushed off and got a DNA model.
I went into the coffee room and asked who'd got one.
The only one I can find is this one,
which is a bit dusty and light the damage DNA in
the Nobel prize. This one's also damaged.
So I went back to the coffee room and got
something a bit more reliable.
These are the spares for the old coffee machine.
Unfortunately, we don't use that coffee machine anymore.
So I'm a bit restricted in what I've got for the model,
but it's enough util understand,
just remember your genetic information,
genetic information of all living things in the world are
transmitted through DNA.
DNA is a molecule that has two chains linked together.
The linkages between the two chains are what carries the genetic
information and can be translated into the
making of proteins in your body. In the Nobel announcement,
the lady who was explaining it said that each of our bodies
has enough DNA, which if it was stretched out,
would go to the sun and back from the earth 250 times.
So that there's an awful lot of it.
Each time a cell divides the DNA has to be
replicated because one pair of chains has to be made into two pairs
of chains. One for each of the new sales, when that happens,
mistakes can be made and the chemistry inside ourselves can also
damage the DNA. And this damage happens very quickly,
200 times a day, perhaps for a given cell.
So if there wasn't a mechanism to repair this damage,
then we'd all die. Before we were even born.
Now, Brady,
who is very astute says that really what
this Nobel prize is for is the DNA spellchecker that is
correcting mistakes, rather like the spellchecker,
but actually it's better than the spellchecker because I don't know about your
spellchecker,
but mine sometimes puts in the completely the wrong word because it misses
guesses. What we've done. Now, let me try and explain to you.
And for,
I explain it's important to realize that there are lots of different
ways that DNA can be damaged and repaired,
but this is a really high-speed explanation.
And we really need to do a proper video about DNA,
and that will be coming quite soon. I hope, but for the moment,
what happens with DNA is that you have, I have two chains,
which are indicated by this white piece of it plastic.
And in between you have so-called base pairs,
which for this,
I've just indicated the things that pair together arrived,
the lime green or dark green, okay.
It's slightly more complicated, but for this that's enough.
Now the first sort of mistake is that one of the DNA changed.
The one that's rowing could have the wrong pair.
We look at this and this is just a tiny, tiny piece of the DNA chain,
which would go on for miles in either direction. So here you have dark green,
dark green, lime, lime, dark lime. And then here,
there's a mismatch. Now,
if you mentioned that the one on this side is the chain that's growing,
that's being synthesized the way the spell checking works
is that there is, it knows which one is the good,
so it can spot the mistake.
It should have been dark green and it's lime green.
So what happens is that there are enzymes in the mechanism that chops
out the bit that's bad and puts in the new one.
You have to imagine that in the cell,
there are lots of these free things swimming around.
So you can always throw one away and not do another one.
It's just like in theory, at least on your computer,
there's an infinite supply of letters. So if you type an O instead of a,
a, you just throw away the Oh, and type another eight.
So the first way is that you can just chop these things out.
There is another sort of mistake where there's a chemical
reaction that damages one of these bases.
And actually for example, turns this into something else which I've done red,
which is for those of you who by chemists is usually
indicated with the letter U.
So this one is one that shouldn't be in DNA at all.
So there's another mechanism that was discovered by Thomas Lindo,
where this is chopped out. And the right one is put in, in state.
The final sort of mechanism is the one which is
causes or is thought to cause some sorts of skin cancer from the UV
light, from the sun.
And this is slightly different where everything is okay in the completed DNA
chain. And then the UV light comes the UV light.
I'm showing with the stapler and it just staples
to two of the bases together. So-called theming.
What it does is the UV light changes one of the theming molecules.
So it reacts with its neighbor.
This only happens where there two of them next to each other.
And of course that messes everything up. But there is a different mechanism,
which was discovered by the researchers in the United States,
which chops out this pair,
that to join together and replaces them with two more teas,
which are not joined together. Now,
the importance of all of this is that it's what keeps us
alive. It's understanding the fundamental mechanisms.
There are other ways that DNA can be damaged. For example, if you smoke,
some of the chemicals that come out in the cigarette smoke can
interact with the DNA and damage the bases.
And there are mechanisms that take this and deal with it. Of course,
smoking has not been around very long.
So evolution has not got a special and to smoking
repair mechanism. But what it has done is to have a mechanism,
a generalized mechanism to detect things are wrong and weed them out.
Speaking of DNA damage,
I took this out of my colleague's office while he was giving a lecture,
didn't even ask him.
So don't tell him I actually dropped a piece and trod on it.
So we'll never repair the damage to this DNA, but all being well,
the mutation won't cause any serious problem.
And you can see, I can't read it from here,
but it's about 173 grams.